for a lot of you this is going to be a
really tough next three four five months
because it's gonna be the first time
that you're ever going to have to fire
someone lay them off maybe in Mass maybe
four five six people out of your 10
person company but this headline is very
real it's hard and you've got to be
prepared for people to react very poorly
remember that they'll be scared and
concerned and struggling so compassion
is humongous you know when you go
through this it's just super hard I've
struggled with this my whole career but
I just want to say that you can do it
you can get through it be as generous as
he can afford to be on the severance be
as generous as it can be with your time
trying to help them get out their jobs
but most of all be heavily compassionate
understand the score the reality is that
there's layoffs and they're starting you
know it's gonna be harder to get another
job and people are going to be
struggling out there and the most you
can do is be gracious and as kindness